[Music]
BTS star jinn just released a new single
and fans are losing their minds
I know your head
[Music]
on Tuesday the singer dropped tonight
and tweeted about the inspiration behind
the lyrics quote I wrote this song while
thinking of my pet it's my first
original song but I hope you enjoy it
next time I'll work hard on my music
again and let you listen Thank You army
that's right the new music honors Jin's
pet sugar glider who passed away
[Music]
the BTS army went gaga over the track
making it the fastest BTS related song
to reach 1 million streams on soundcloud
in less than 30 minutes thank you for
those are the armies you made today I
love you
you gave ologies team a dollars we're so
proud and so grateful thank you this is
June 2nd solo song following last year's
epiphany from the group's album love
yourself answer tonight was released as
a part of BTS Festa a celebration that
takes place every year to celebrate the
band's debut this year Festa will go on
for 11 days culminating on June 13th to
coincide with their 6th anniversary and
the army is all about it today in what
do you think about kids not going to
school so they can see you play
volleyball we're an opponent
watch TV please sorry but we're living
in 2017 you can watching YouTube maybe
later haha
[Music]